could Laurie Lachlan and her husband
Massimo Jian Ulis finally have the
evidence they need to prove their
innocence in the college admissions
scandal their attorneys seem to think so
this is the strongest evidence we've
seen so far to suggest that she and her
husband didn't know what these payments
were about an recently filed court
documents the couple's defense attorneys
claimed the prosecutors provided them
with notes written by the alleged
mastermind of the scheme Rik singer
they say the notes allegedly written on
singer's iPhone prove Laurie and
Massimo's claim that they did not bribe
their daughters way into USC
both gia Neely and Lachlan have pleaded
not guilty to all charges leveled
against them you have the ringleader
basically saying that he was asked to
lying about what he told these parents
according to the court documents singers
notes allegedly indicate the FBI agent
yelled at him and instructed him to lie
to his clients by calling their payments
brides even if he'd previously
categorized them as legitimate they also
note the government's desire to nail one
of the defendants at all costs this is
all about intent what was their intent
in making the payments did they think
that these were legitimate donations to
USC in order to help their daughter's
chances of getting into the university
that's their defense to have the
ringleader saying that the FBI forced
him to lie to basically say that the FBI
told me to say that oh these were not
legitimate payments these parents knew
what they were doing was illegal when
really that was not the case that's huge
and here's the thing the court documents
were filed on Wednesday afternoon less
than 24 hours before Lori and Massimo's
trial date was to be set federal
prosecutors say they discovered singer's
personal notes back in October 2018 but
believed they were privileged at the
time and held off on disclosing them
until yesterday this doesn't look good
for the prosecution this kind of
evidence was
supposed to be turned over about 30 days
after the indictments that didn't happen
so the question is why did prosecutors
not turn over this evidence two years
ago were they trying to hide something a
source close to the couple's team
exclusively alleges to ET that this
latest evidence quote clearly shows that
the government was using bullying
tactics and intimidation in an effort to
bolster their lack of evidence in this
case Lachlan and her husband are accused
of paying $500,000 in bribes to get
their daughters 21 year-old Isabella and
20 year-old Olivia Jade admitted to USC
as recruits for the crew team even
though neither of them had ever
participated in the sport they do want
them to have somewhat of a normal you
know finish out of high school college
experience maybe because I didn't have
that I would really want that for them
while the new evidence may help prove if
Lori and Massimo are innocent in regards
to paying bribes they're also accused of
making fake resumes and staging photos
of their daughters participating in Cru
Lori locklins best defense is to try to
play stupid that she never intended to
do anything illegal
she was directed by Rick singer he was
the one who wasn't telling the truth and
he was the one who told her yeah
everything's on the up-and-up yeah just
take these pictures do this to the
resume it's fine it happens a million
times you're not doing anything wrong
this is what has to be done and the
money it's just to don't it's just a
donation to the school happens all the
time common practice you're not doing
anything illegal our source says that
Lori and Massimo continue to maintain
their innocence as they have from day
one their trial has been set for October
5th it will take place at a federal
courthouse in Boston and is expected to
take at least four weeks
[Music]